hey I'm Joe Weisenthal co-host of what
you met today's chart is based on an
economic data that just came out this is
the jolts index specifically this line
shows the number of job openings in
America this is data from July it's a
little bit dated this in report is kind
of like the jobs report except it shows
things like quits and job openings and
other stuff like that anyway as you
could see the number of open jobs in
America just is it 5.7 million it's the
highest in history you know down during
the crisis there are hardly any job
openings left now it's like really come
way back and this really seems to have
accelerated lately so if you're looking
for a job or if you're looking for a
wage hike and you want higher higher pay
this is likely a very good sign that
both of those things could happen you're
more likely to find a job obviously when
job openings are high you're more likely
to be able to have bargaining power with
your employer when you know lots of
people are trying to find workers so
this is another good sign and as Janet
Yellen thinks about raising rates
there's another sign perhaps that the
labor market is getting a bit tighter
and that's my color chart watch would
you miss it for p.m. Euston
you